[Music]
for
a
[Music]
all
I
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
[Laughter]
m for
[Music]
is
w oh
[Music]
all
now
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
your e
oh
[Music]
a e
oh
[Music]
May
uh okay uh I'm sorry uh yeah um let's
yeah yeah I was asking CHD sorry I don't
know what to do
I'm bit lost no I'm just kidding I
actually know what I'm doing so uh let's
um talk about atic so namely how to how
can you do things to state in some
contract or just make the chain say that
something happened I'm Z I'm a deal
engineer at AE
Labs I'm very glad to be here I'm very
is a big deal to me so it seems like my
clicker is not still
thing uh
okay oh yeah to turn it on so yeah
there's this person um I guess someone
that likes ethereum I was like thinking
whether ethereum is actually the real
life or not
and I met someone else that was also the
same I would say conference and they
were thinking if it's actually just
fantasy um and there was also like
someone that CH oh I'm kidding okay this
is too much um I'm going to you I'm
going to yeah I just came out of bed
anyway but uh what I want to do is just
that you actually can't represent the
real life in a global Ledger because
causality in real life is private but
let's okay let's start from the
beginning this is too much let's start
how can you represent the real life if
you're using the world's most expensive
clock which is
ethereum so let's start with some
agenda yeah I even have an agenda it's
really cool so let's talk about the
secret to success this is something I
know I'm give it going to give it to you
then I'm going to tell you who you are
and then finally oh tell about the
world's uh most expensive time stamp
machine which again is ethereum and then
I'm going to explain to you how can you
cre your secrets when you shout them out
loud there's going to be a demo at the
end um at the end most most of the time
it's going to be a live demo for you to
also uh try in your own
machines so the secret to success and
happiness I
know what is the secrets to success and
happiness and I'm going to give it to
you for free because I like you and
there are only
two simple steps right first one is you
have to tr yourself okay you're going to
take all the real life assets you're
going to put them in a global immutable
public Ledger okay if it seems like
something you've seen before that's just
a coincidence nobody's doing this right
publicly nobody is doing this right and
then uh you just became a dictator I
mean it's perfect like you just can be
happy be successful you can do whatever
you want uh it's amazing right uh but if
you're not a dictator I'm not and if you
want to be a dictator then who do you
want to be who are
you you need
something right so I asked some
worldclass scientists about this uh
except not but anyway I would talk I for
example I talk with some physicists they
said yeah definitely I can represent
people as uh having a deterministic
position velocity I have actually have
some code here you can write uh a stru
that has a position and velocity but
actually do you need that do I need that
to see that you are here you you do have
a position in velocity but it's private
I don't actually need to know that as
long as we agree what time is it and
that there's a common time I don't need
to know that I can actually see the
consequence of a cause without knowing
the cause the same for biology you can
have some blood pressure pressure you
can have I mean whatever glycose levels
um again as long as we agree on a common
sense of time I know that you are here
and you are alive so again this struct
is completely private can be
private psychologists say the same thing
you have some memories memories are
important because they they rule the way
that you uh you engage with the world
and still I can see that you are
engaging with the world
so you are social being so this is also
something that affects the real life and
now you're like why what does this has
to do with with atic right you're just
talking about random stuff I say no
because because actually so far all
blockchains imply full knowledge of all
the public
inputs everyone needs to agree on
everything and everyone needs to know
everything and that's what ask the the
couples so actually the world is
actually not random it's just like you
just see a ton of private execution that
happens in our brains and even in nature
and we just don't know about it and it
still affects our envirment
so privacy is quite a big deal isn't it
it's it's kind of also a human right and
this is I mean this just little book
that says that you actually privacy is
actually human right it's I mean it's
just a universal Declaration of the
human right right so it's kind of a big
deal you can't just ignore it you also
cannot like just ignore it you cannot uh
ask someone to keep privacy to say oh
I'm you can promise you that I'll I'll
keep your data there's even laws like
gdpr that says that there are people
saying oh yeah yeah I'm trust your your
password will be safe with me please
yeah don't you can trust me etc etc etc
but actually if you go and think about
the blockchain blockchain without
privacy is a a willing nightmare so
there's a problem here that we need to
figure out
right here's a tweet about about privacy
on guard that I really like it's like
everyone is oh there's this new new uh
thing blockchain we're going to rule the
world it's going to crack down on
financials uh it's going to be a big
deal but then let's just put everything
publicly on a public Ledger what right
are we mad like this is just this is
just wrong
right so in short we are encoded with
our secrets in real life uh this is an
example I hate brokoli so that's
something I can add to my rep
presentation and I actually I don't have
to tell you that if we going to go to a
restaurant or something I'm going to
choose a plate that has no broccoli
because I know that I don't I don't like
broccoli and I actually I can even
influence you to choose another plate
that it's not broccoli because I don't
know you just found that whatever I
choose is best and you would you would
choose broccoli if I wasn't there so I
just kind of shouted that I hate
broccoli without revealing anything I
I'm not leaking any any information
about me you just you just see the
consequence of an action without knowing
the causality and with blockchains
everyone is leaking everyone is leaking
your data and this is something that
your data just can't leave your machine
if it leaves your machine it's not
private anymore so let's do something um
I promised there's going to be a
workshop this is a workshop a real
Workshop you can drive our
machines um so here's an an
agenda um going to boot up like this
world's most expensive clock then write
some programmable privacy and then run
it maybe it's not uh yeah maybe I should
do it in
a put more information here so yeah
we're going to set up this development
environment we call it the sandbox
because it comes with pxc and everything
inside um we're also going to like
generate some
useful typ script bindings okay I'm
kidding uh we're going to deploy with a
with a CLI
but then we're going to write the TS
bind because they are useful but that's
that's fine you can leave now no
questions asked right um then we're
going to write our deployer which it's I
mean it's also types script that's fine
there's a script that does most of the
thing most of things for
you then writing a contract which is
going to be very useless it's the voting
contract that everyone can see what the
t is Right completely useless but still
interesting because there's still some
private execution because and no one can
see uh who you voted for I think that's
Ah that's okay for a
workshop and then some uh bonus points
for for testing just just seeing that it
works I mean maybe it won't maybe I I'll
make some mistakes and yeah
anyway um then I'm going to go on the
good stuff which will
be private native account
abstraction which is kind of amazing
like it it is really really really good
stuff but yeah maybe for another day
just I just wanted to say that we have
native private execution native private
C obstruction which is really amazing um
for uh private Network and then enough
memes we can hack um this is the QR code
for the Noir docks for the Aztec doc
sorry um there's a link tree right here
with the dogs as well yeah so that's the
azc Discord
you can join I hope the link is still
active and there's the link to the
documentation we'll probably have that
as well and then yeah my link tree has
my socials and also some Workshop
resources there's a kind of a shet sheet
you can you can use for stuff that I'm
going to just copy paste so you can run
it on your machines as well if I didn't
forget anything and I think we're good
like to to start
just going to wait to stop having phones
in the
air okay cool so I hope you you can hear
me now
still cool so let's HCK
um here's the so LinkedIn here you can
have a code space if you for whatever
reason like you're using Windows or
something and you don't have a Linux or
a Mac machine you can use this code
space It should work uh it comes with
the sandbox so the first part actually
already done for you um there's this
code Snippets you can go and this is
just going to open this page uh which
has uh most of the stuff that you you
will need um yeah actually I should have
these notes here as well so if I there's
also like some sheets here at the end
probably going to use those if I if I
miss
something uh so the first thing we're
going to do just open a new project
um I
can start a Sandbox so to install the
sandbox you can go and just run this
that's the first snippet you go here you
install it and this will install some uh
useful uh CLI tools um just say Yes um
it will install the wallet the nargo
which is compiler and Aztec which is the
chain
basically just taking track of
time and once that's done most of just
Docker images as you probably recognize
that I think the font should be is it
can you read it or should I make it
bigger uh bigger yeah cool is it good
now all cool thank you so yeah now you
can start this unbox you can go WTIC
start most of the commands are actually
here already for auto complete so you
can go ASC start SL sandbox and this
will start the sandbox sandbox is just
andil okay no big deal um layer one
pretend to be a layer one and then
there's the layer two the Aztec uh node
that is starting we'll kind of register
some accounts I mentioned native account
abstraction um mostly because so you
know that any contract is actually uh
any account is actually a contract so
that could be useful um in a bit
so then we can start with the writing an
app so I can go
npx atic app in it and actually this
didn't didn't work for me yesterday so I
may have to write the whole thing anyway
this atic up in it will hopefully it
will probably ask you to install a app
this is just um yeah it's it it didn't
work I don't know why there's something
here with get
sorry yeah yeah yeah I can wait yeah
yeah um so yeah there's something here
um that is um not correct so I'll
probably have to write most of the stuff
um actually since I'm since we are
waiting I can actually go to the
Aztec uh GitHub and just go and copy
that so we can start quickly so boxes
and then there's uh okay not boxes is uh
um in it yeah here and yeah this is what
it should be cloning but for whatever
reason it's
not actually I'm going to put this in
the resources here as well so you can
follow
along if you're looking
into
sorry the QR yes uh here you can look at
that is it good the sandbox are still
still
downloading it's low
yeah that's we can wait a bit more
that's fine um yeah I'm just going to
copy this so to just take care of what
this was not called
cloning
and yeah you see there's some scribble
errors and this is because I haven't um
out of the the
dependency I actually want to talk a bit
about dependency so this is uh there's
some questions around what is the the
relationship between R and azc and this
is a good question like this is actually
inir if you've written any inir you know
how it looks like why is it why did it
copy twice I don't know
um this is um but you see some things
like this macros and what what are these
and this is uh stuff that is going to be
injected by the astec dependency so
astec NR astec andr is just the
dependency that you can import just like
any other Library so you do that in
nargo dosl and here is the the path
which is wrong I think that's why it it
wasn't cloning correctly so but I
actually I have here the dependency so
this is just importing this particular
dependency
um from the from the Cod
Snippets um so yeah it's just just a
library right no big deal and so once
you save that you'll hopefully this will
stop screaming at you yeah okay uh more
or less anyway there's as you can see
there's a an LSP so uh it actually help
you autocomplete stuff uh which is
really cool still kind of in the works
but um I mean it's useful
anyway
so
yeah to turn on lights is it can can we
turn on the lights just these lights to
make it easier to
read thank you ah
perfect cool so yeah I hope the sendbox
is
downloaded um if not you can use the the
code space it's going to probably be
faster and actually can even use the the
sandbox it's will port forward to your
machine
um so yeah going back to the Cod
Snippets I'm going to import these
dependencies as well these are just um
things that we'll need that we want to
import from the
Aztec um dependency again this is no so
we want to be sure that you want you're
not importing the whole thing you just
import what you're actually going to be
needing and this is what we're going to
need we're going to get the public keys
this is to get the Notifier and and
also uh the initializer function
internal private public those are like
macros that you're going to be needing
uh storage and then the types of the
stuff we're going to be storing which is
going to be just the Aztec address a map
just like a map on ethereum and then
public mutable which is as a name says
it's something that is actually public
and everyone can change or it can be
changed in public so we are going to
actually you know and Define our storage
so storage you go and say storage right
no no big deal uh and just Define
storage so there's there's this context
thing that we need to pass wasn't here
now wasn't here before now it is that's
something we need to guess figure out
how how to get rid of this context kind
of annoying so this is where our
structure comes into play so the way
that we're going to be doing this is our
election or voting thing will have an
admin admin will be we'll see everyone's
votes it's really cool uh there's
probably going only going to be one
candidate because that's that's how
democracy works I'm just kidding um and
then there's going to be a Tal
tell everyone can see that so actually
all the stor is going to be public which
is fine it's just as easy as make it
private actually it's even sometimes
harder to do stuff in public than it is
in private uh so going to Define an
admin I'm going to say admin is going to
be uh a public mutable um Aztec
address so this is going to be us right
the deployer and then T um this is a map
so
map it just like any theem I'm going to
use what we call a Phil which is um um a
native type in inir just kind of
represents you can think of it as just
representing a number I would probably
uh probably going to be killed by saying
this but it's you can treat it as a bit
of a kind of a big integer yeah yeah I
hope there's no as team members to kill
me now anyway uh and this map will be
just um map in between a number that
will be represent presting a candidate
and then the number of votes um so field
and this is going to be public mutable
because all the votes are Public public
mutable
field uh this is where I think I need to
pass the contexts somewhere
everywhere uh I think here context and I
think as well here
context um cool and so that's that's how
it goes the way that we're going to okay
let's just actually start with
initializer so let's make it I think uh
public yeah it's fine I think uh
initializer uh you can actually call it
anything uh you don't have to call it
Constructor um I'm just going to call it
Constructor because that's how usually
people call Constructors but uh and I'm
going to pass the ASC address as
the as the initializer and this will
just set me as the admin so I'm going to
say storage
um admin and then write uh admin okay I
don't need
to return anything so this should
actually compile if I didn't do anything
wrong that's a stri let's just try
compiling um astec nargo so ASC nargo is
nargo is if you know Noir is just the
compiler for for Noir so asak Naro I
here it's actually now now it's the same
thing it wasn't the same thing some time
ago but it is now but for some reason
still call last Naro so yeah just it's t
of warnings warnings are not thereor so
just ignore it I'm just kidding but yeah
uh we're going to eventually have to fix
the warnings as well um but yeah compile
like you can see here is like there's
the there's the here's the in main thing
that seems to be working so yeah I'm I'm
happy for now um so yeah it's kind of
useless that it just deploys and that's
that's it so let's do something else um
which me me see my notes uh if I didn't
forget anything no I didn't cool so
we're going to write the logic the logic
is not very complex we're just going to
write a private function so private
function executes client side and the
only thing that goes out is just a proof
and that's what's going to be screaming
out loud you're going to be screaming
out loud actually you're going to be
calling a public function say oh add
another vote to the to the to this
candidate and they like oh but the
candidate is going to be public no it's
not like I mean candidate is but who who
voted is not so your your privacy is
still preserved even though we're just
saying to the note yeah please add
another vote to this candidate so that's
that's part going to be working in in
public which is really cool so to define
a private function you just do the same
thing you just Define private and then
just right let's right cast vote cast
vote and this should be um I'm going to
have a candidate it's going to be also
filled um because it's just like one two
three four five
whatever um so good uh now we want to
basically the way we're going to do be
doing this is there's a nullifier we're
going to create for this specific app
there's going to be a nullifier and this
nullifier will actually
be um so you can't nullify twice right
for this app you only can notify once
with your key uh surely you could rotate
keys and that's something that was
actually in our road map but I think uh
we're going to drop that um but yeah
it's kind of useless right You' have to
do a do a different logic so let's call
it um
NPK M this just a nullifier um key and
uh just call it get the keys that's what
we defined before for account so I'm
going to use context message sender here
this is just basically me right and then
just get the nullifier key
um uh hash you see the auto complete
here doing its job thank you because
I'll definitely forget it so now I have
that I need to create the nullifier for
this specific app you don't want to use
the nullifier for everything otherwise
people could actually track and see
where are you adding or nullifiers and
it could be a leaking privacy so you
want to have one specific for for app so
say like
NPK um app yeah something like that and
this could be
um uh how do how did I do this last last
time was like
uh I think
npkm
h npm no NP k
m hash and
then I not it anywhere don't want to
mess it up okay it says I think it's
here no it's not this one um let me
check my
notes
um I actually I have the shits here in
the so I don't
forget around
here yeah okay yeah it's a context yeah
I know it was something that was already
there so context yeah you get of course
it's context because it's like the
private context um you're just saying
yeah in private please get the nullifier
for this specific app so you get uh
where is this request and and NSK up and
just send the master um noar key and
this should I I think that's fine and
this should be um good to nullify so to
nullify basically I'm just going to do
something that can can't be hopefully uh
replicated or just attacked in any way
so I'm going to Define like a secret let
secret and do that secret uh it's going
to be a hush this is actually R so you
can use whatever hash is in the standard
Library so I'm going to do that uh for
example I think the easiest one is is p
going hash and then um
pson and Pon hash yeah and then it's
going to be
context um need a context uh this could
be message
sender uh to field right yeah it needs
to be a field and then another field
could
be uh the npkm hush I think yeah this is
a field cool looks good so now I have a
secret um oh wait not not Secret
nullifier
um yeah that's this one is a secret
um so now I can push this nullifier to
my uh private execution environment so
private execution environment is
actually a that is running on your
machine because again if your private
inputs leave your machine they're not
private anymore so going to say
context private context context is real
really cool word because if I if I call
context in in a public function like an
initializer it will actually look
different friend um so it's um it's a
cool one so I'm going to say context and
then I think it's push
nullifier uh
nullifier uh read request I didn't have
those in my note maybe it was a new
version
see yeah I hope this works still um I'm
pushing this
nullifier and then um where where is I
get that and then we're good like we
have nullifier we can basically say I
can't vot vote twice because if you try
to vote twice it will say uh already the
secret is already the the this app so
you can't unless you have a different
counter you can rotate your keys then
you can't vote twice and if you can't
vote twice that means that you already
voted so if this function calls the
public function then you're good it will
means that your vote is actually not be
able you're not going to be able to do
it twice so I can Define here a public
function going to call public function
uh just want to be sure I do the same
naming because of
the the
interface uh oh yeah I called it a toal
a
toal and this will take the candidate
which will come from the other function
and say uh storage this is the the
easiest function ever just just going to
get the tally at the candidates and just
read it okay going add that to like call
it preview or something previews and
then this will basically it's a public
it's public so I can read it tell is
completely public I said at candidate at
this mapping just get the number of
things and then just write that plus one
right storage um wait what what is
happening here storage uh
tally at
candidate uh right right preview plus
one all this should be okay we want to
call this function so I'm going to call
that in a previous function say the name
of the
contract is composable so I could
actually have two contracts that's fine
as long as I had an interface just like
ethereum so I can go main this case I
don't need it's the same contract so I
can say main at um
this is going to be I think context and
then uh this address I
think
um and then I think it's the name of the
adal candidate it's that candidate and
then I need to in this because I'm going
to ask the I mean I could have different
one different um public functions it
will just go so so I'd say
inq and then I'm going to pass uh public
mutable
context not public yeah it's private
actually cool I think this should
compile if I didn't mess up anything
okay aho happy uh now there's just one
thing that we need which is to read it
right and to read it it's actually not
hard because your private execution
environment is synced with the network
it should be synced with the network so
just read from that it's just like a
view function on on ethereum except
you're not calling anything to get your
function you're actually getting it
yourself because you're synced with the
network really cool isn't it like you an
un constr function it's actually a view
function is actually just calling your
own machine so so I go
unconstrained this means that there's no
this is not even a circuit it's just uh
just computation so like plane
computation uh so in constrain function
and I can call uh how did I call it last
time just H I don't have that just like
like get T maybe this should be get t
for one candidate this could be filled I
have to I want to return that I want to
say public field so in Noir you always
have to make returns public because they
are actually inputs
so and just read and say
storage um T at
candidate rate returning that so no need
to add
the return also no need to add the semic
colon at the end so this should
be compiling cool so we have our
contract we can deploy this let's do
that uh let me just check the
time okay we're good so to deploy we can
use Aztec wallet Aztec wallet is CLI
tool
um we are actually working with uh
people to actually make this an actual
wallet but we just developed the C tool
there's one person that has building
that um but yeah you can use the CLI
tool and basically just same thing just
need to add a a uh graphical interface
and there's obviously the question or
where is your pxc running that's another
that's another discussion uh in this
case the private execution environment
is running inside your sandbox and this
is important because later on you're
going to actually be intiating a a um a
pxc client and you're going to say how
is this how is this private it is
because the sandbox already has um a
private execution
environment uh but in a test net that's
that's another thing because there's no
there's you're not running your own
network so you want to keep that the pxc
private
um and the name implies right private
execution environment cool um so let's
just start a wallet um a wallet is
really really cool the way that um the
team has been building this so just open
this a bit more because you can actually
do pretty much everything and most of
all you can define an allias allias are
cool because you can for example deploy
two contracts or two accounts and again
give them different different allias and
then just refer to them later on instead
of having to copy weird um like weird
exod decimal strings of the addresses
and stuff so going to a
Wallet create account uh I'm actually
going to reuse the same so I don't I
don't mess it up um so yeah I'm defining
here a is going to be theas and say my
account so when it deploys it will
actually so here's the account public
key Etc and then just like stored in a
local database saying there is the my
account also an allias called last so
you don't if you don't Define it it just
like assume that it's the last one which
is also really really cool so to deploy
this I'm there's another say another one
that says
deploy again reusing what I've done
yesterday so I didn't okay there's just
here I need to change so it says Aztec
deploy from the account that we just
created that has thei accounts you just
say from this account I'm going toplay
I'm going
to I'm going to deploy this one called
init main so it will you can actually
use the name of the package and then the
name of the contract like this in it at
Main it will figure out its own thing
and then just send the the the arguments
so that's the initializer we we're
saying that the initializer takes the
admin which is us so I'm going to pass
that and then also can create an another
allias calling this my contract so it's
saved under this address so it is
deploying to my network through my XE
that's stored in database so it's called
like now it's called my contract so at
this point you're like okay maybe I can
get to tally right now I can I can see
it should be zero right hopefully uh so
we can try we can say uh as quallet and
then simulate because see why do you
want to simulate it because you're
actually not calling another another
note you're WR you're getting it from
your from your pxc so it's just
simulating uh simulating transaction no
need to call anything because also that
would reveal data you don't want to
reveal like who are you asking for and
you don't want that you just want to get
your own stuff so we just pass the
contract as address as your contract the
contract we just deployed from I'm
making this call from my account so and
then just get the t is it called get t
uh yeah get tell oh okay just saying
like for candidate one for example so
that's going to be arguments one one and
hopefully this will get me zero okay
cool zero that's a big in we like bigs
so that's a b um now I want to vote let
me see an
quallet uh send because here I'm sending
a transaction I'm I'm executing a
private transaction that will actually
make a call uh on the public side later
around
so same here just saying contract
address it's the same contract address
from my account and I'm casting a vote
with for the candidate one just doing
that uh cannot find the Le for nullifier
oh I think this is probably because of
that thing that is B request personal
fire let me see if this works should
work and need to
compile yeah I don't know
the so I hav an so I can deploy from
yeah I can deploy now I think
yes okay so now I can send
it h what's happening
I'm uh I
compiled just get my just going to copy
the chats from for this I know this work
I tried that
yesterday
so oh yeah uh I forgot the internal
which is cool otherwise you could
actually call this public function and
that random votes not probably what we
want
[Applause]
so um try to compile that again andly
please
work okay it works yeah I don't know I
think it was an internal thing that was
missing anyway uh now it says like yeah
I did make a transaction actually
transaction has an allias so if you want
to get like the transaction hash or
stuff that that's fine you can you can
do that so now if I call the get T again
I can where is this uh simulate if I get
tell it should add one and just to prove
that it works I can actually try to vote
again and hopefully it will fail yeah it
says that it's it's the it's unable to
be added to the state and it's Evol I
think it doesn't even like do anything
because it can prove it can't make false
proof that it just says yeah can't can't
go further than this so so far so good
I'm actually happy for this and let me
see just the
time cool we're going to have some time
for questions which is really really
cool um so doing doing the wallets is
cool you probably want to do this in a
browser
so first thing you want to do is install
bun right okay this is if you don't like
JavaScript if you don't like typescript
if you're like me just use bun okay it's
really cool you just use a typescript
you write typescript and it works okay
so if you want to do that just go and
the last time going to run an npm
command so go npm I G and then bun right
and this will install bun okay please
please do that it will yeah it will save
yeah first thing you should do in an
machine um so now that we have burn we
can go like actually start a new project
and say just uh just create
index.ts
um yeah I think I can I can go with the
browser already uh don't need to um yeah
just just let's just immediately start
with the browser I could show like a
little test script but I really want to
show you the browser maybe it will fail
there's many things that can fail with
the browser but still could be cool to
to show you how can you actually use um
an app like an actual web browser app
and use it to vote privately isn't that
amazing like it's really cool so uh for
that I'm going to use
npx uh or yeah it's called BN burx which
is the same thing I just I just don't
like npx yeah I'm kidding npx that that
works as well um npx and then create
V uh here's the command it just starts
um a template so I mean I can actually
do this create VD and just like this and
you ask me uh what I want I say yeah
just ignore and just add your files to
here just going to choose react and then
choose tab script react and here I have
a like very simple app that just uh
hopefully
works and I can actually try to run it B
rev and uh okay what is B randev is not
here oh okay I I forgot to install
dependencies so here I have I mean it
should be working like just the normal
bur app just want to be sure okay cool
so let's start writing some some stuff I
want to do two install two kinds of
dependencies the first one is the Aztec
dependency so Aztec JS and Aztec
accounts these are Aztec JS is the
interface to Aztec uh it allows you to
call contracts to interface with your
pxc so that's what it does and atic
accounts provide provides you an easy
way to create accounts we're actually
going to use a testing account because I
mean it's just a a workshop no need to
we actually using test account is cool
because it creates a new one every time
so you can actually have more than one
vote if you just restart the app um
so yeah install that um one thing is
like ascj is not yet really optimized
for the browser so we're going to be
using some polyfill so if you know a bit
of
JavaScript you you know that JavaScript
can be run on the browser and and the
know at the same time which is cool but
also a bit annoying because I mean
JavaScript was made to make things FL
flashing the screen and we actually
suddenly make it in the browser in the
in the the node um so yeah we're just
installing some po poly fills to say
I've written this for node but I also
want it to work in the browser so to do
that I'm going to install some VD
plugins oh here they are top level wa
and
the poly fills top level weight I don't
even know why is it there like by
default most browsers already allow you
to use top level weight which would mean
like just writing a weight here um but
yeah for some reason I need to use a a
plugin for that and then node polyfills
it's just what I just mentioned some
stuff that is in the node but not in the
browser so I want to have that so let me
call top level waight from
V top level weight and then import I
think this is a named import um which is
a node polyils
uh from we node polyils and just using
that just plugin top level and then not
poly
fills okay so I'm good I think it won't
break um so we're good to actually write
some um some code
um oh one thing I I need to
do uh I mean I don't need to but I want
to do is to create an interface so
really cool about uh things in Aztec is
like you can actually create a
typescript interface that makes it very
easy to interact with the contract so if
you go astec
Cen I'm going to point this Cen to my
target which is here so this stuff has
actually all it's a bit of an an a as
you can see it also has all the bite
code and everything so it's there's a
point where just can't yeah it's not
human rual but the first part is and so
it can actually use that to generate an
interface to say oh you can call these
and these and these types um to these
functions and so that's what is going to
be doing into the artifacts folder so
look at this really really cool like you
can you can call this function this is a
class you can call this class and get
like pointed at the different addresses
that deploy it and and most of all it
allows you to call these functions so
you could just import that that uh this
this file and just use it as as you want
it so uh Codine is really really
powerful so um I'm going to actually
kill this uh index
TS um also going to I deploy this I'm
going to deploy again just because I
need I want a fresh
contract deploy
um so we don't see we only see one vote
hopefully um so I have here the
deployment just called I mean add a new
file say deploy text just so I I don't
lose it in the in the history the
terminal
history so now I'm going here to my uh I
think app. TSX it should be okay and I'm
going to
um instantiate a new wallet and say oh
here's a new wallet again it's kind of
stupid because if I redeploy if I just
refresh the page I'll get a new wallet
because it's a testing testing wallet so
if you're probably if we restart we're
going to be seeing like two V three vs
that's fine um and so here's like uh
import and um I want to import the stuff
from MC so um I guess create pxc
client um
from Aztec JS I want to create an
account so create
account uh from astec accounts going to
call the testing ones so if you see here
it's really cool like it just creates a
random random account um and then I want
my interface uh import main I think it's
also named main contract
uh from uh where is it artifacts M right
is it called main contract yeah it is
cool so um first thing I want to
instantiate my pxc so I'm going to so
say pxc create pxc client I'm going to
pass the URL so as I mentioned pxc is
running on my machine because it's part
of the sandbo tooling so HTTP Local Host
880 now you see what's the problem with
pxc where where does it run if it has
your public in your private inputs where
does it run it need to run your nor
machine right if you're using Aztec you
want your public your private inputs to
remain private and they need to run on a
phone they need to run on a desktop
whatever you're using your wallet your
inputs can't leave this place so in my
case it's not leaving my place it's just
calling my own server um so that's why
it's 880 where where is the sandbox is
running so I can go pxc create pxc
client Etc now I want to create an
account so just going to say let's call
this wallet actually and say create
account oh create
account create account and passing the
pxc so it registers in the pxc and says
here's here's my account so now I should
have a wallets I can I'm good to
actually go and uh I already have deplo
the contract so let's just go on the
standard um oh wait standard react
development here um
as with every react uh development you
just remove everything right first thing
that's uh because you don't care and
you're going to write three functions
those are like uh starting just to
getting my my my contract address and
everything um an interface and I'm going
to also uh be able to vote and then I'm
going to be able to see the votes and
that's enough so I'm going to write uh
an init functions called a sync um
this is uh okay for example
contract con contract going to say
await main
contract at uh the address that we here
we have stor here I mean usually we
actually deploy with JS which is also
like just main contract. deploy not big
deal I'm going to pass that here also my
wallet
it's probably yeah it's going of
complain because it says oh it needs to
be an ntec address that's fine just cast
that to an ntec address and say from
from string and says cool I just get a
string I just pass it just convert it to
a
NC thing also I think I need to wait
here cool so I have contract here I'm
going to store that in in
my in my state set contract use State uh
to complain about the type I'm going to
pass the type main contract just make it
be zero then I can set it here set
contract contract so if you know react
this is the kind of standard thing you
would do also this is the first thing I
want to do so I'm going to use effect
create create an effect so it starts
that's the first first thing it does but
I can't I can't use asynchronous
functions in use effect they needs to be
synchronous so I'm going to call in it
here and and then when I render that's
when I'm going to say if there is tally
I'm going to go ahead so to get the
tally I'm going to say get tally um same
thing I
think pretty much the same kind of uh
development flow but now I should have
the
contract uh actually I may not have the
contract so I'm going to go contract
hope it doesn't break um contract and
methods right I want to call all these
methods and as you can see I have all
the methods except the one that it's
public because it's in journal so I get
cast vote and I'm going to pass one
that's my candidate I'm going to send
this is a not simulate it's a oh no
sorry simulate yeah simulate um then
that's it I'm simulate just as long as I
wait that I should be able to get a
tally and
wait and yeah you know what I'm going to
also add that to the state say tally set
tally this point I think I'm my fingers
already know how to write this you know
just uh it's a big and just make it a
zero n does it work
yeah this this thing is new the end
thing um so I can set it here I set T
tell and this is cool uh so it works
should work right now I finally I want
to vote so vote
sync you probably know what I'm about to
do it's just the very same thing I'll
just say wait
contracts
methods cast vote oh wait it's not C
Cast vote here get
T um cast
vote one I'm going to send I'm going to
wait for it wait for it yeah uh
I'm goingon to play this the tally right
I'm gonna wait get tally because I want
just having it shown on screen easily so
now I'm good to write our good old HML
so uh just call it uh voting
contract um just make it
a a paragraph I'm going to say uh
charie uh Chie cannot be there right so
I'm going to may maybe T here then say
um I yeah t so T is um that's why it say
two string because is a is a begin so I
need to go to string and maybe cast it
to base 10
um yeah I think this will work otherwise
it will complain it can't really render
begins and I'm going to add a button as
well so like on click I'm going to go
click and vote
and just okay so vote for the
candidates other candidates are not
available that's
democracy cool so I think this is it
like right I didn't forget anything um
so I can actually go and try bur run
live I'll be surprised if this works oh
yeah uh
yeah it's complaining it
says that it can't resolve FS promises I
think um I may have been too optimistic
about the node poly fills I'm going to
exclude that so exclude just the fs see
if it works this
way yeah okay I'm very
surprised so let's try
it uh it could take a while I think the
JS it's kind of big so that is probably
why or oh cool oh did I get zero nice so
what happens if if I vote I'm going to
open the console because it's probably
going to
error voting for the candidate there's
no spinner or anything like that cool I
have one wo so what happens is I I try
again so hopefully also fail yeah it
fail
cool so let's just restart this and see
it should actually go and see twice if I
start a new new one because uh like the
app is it's going to be um it's going to
create a new account so this should
should actually have one at first like
immediately because it it thinks that
someone has voted already um okay no
it's zero oh because it's zero at the
beginning I don't get the T at the
beginning so that's why but voting it
should be too maybe
yeah cool yeah so it works but if I try
again it will just say oh that key has
already voted that you can do it wise
how cool is this like it's really cool
this doesn't leave your machine like
actually I think the pxc is not proving
because there's a flag that I need to
pass uh these guys should know if I need
to pass a flag so but the proof is not
in this case the proof is not even too
big so it shouldn't it wouldn't even
take a long long time um let me see how
how much time do we have so we can maybe
look at some other code let's
see yeah do you have a lot of questions
or okay I'll would say yes so yeah just
I'll leave like 10 minutes at the end
should be enough so let's look at some
some stuff that has been done
here um first of all we want to look at
the look at the contracts so one one
thing that you may want to know it's
um what about ethereum what's the thing
about etherum you never touched ethereum
apart from using envil um but if you
look at the at the actual sandbox here
um you can actually see that there was a
rollup being made um you see there is
there was a roll up being being being
sent into Anvil and if I do get
the the Anvil logs I should I should say
I should see it um I should see the logs
there the thing is like you can actually
pass messages from L2 to L1 quite easily
so if you see the
documentation um dogs. aztec. Network
you can
see here in the references you can see
um how to do that so I think there's
even an example with that
so here where we will be able to make a
token Bridge so there's an actual
example on what we call portal contracts
this allow you to make message passing
very easily it's done via the sequencer
um so you can basically make it quite
easy to by deploy your contract on L1
and another contract on L2 you can
actually pass messages it will take some
time because I mean there's uh there's
message passing takes time for the blog
time but still it's really interesting
you can actually move funds into into L2
make whatever you want to do and then
maybe pass into a different L1 if you
want to because it's not even like it
it's unrelated with the kind of um um
Network you want to connect to but
obviously there's going to be a rollup
so at the end if you see the
architecture and the resources here
you're going to see that there's going
to be a a rollup that will be done um by
with all the transactions so the
architecture kind of implies that
there's a sequencer the sequencer kind
of order all the transactions as they
want um uh like I think there's going to
be a like a a roll
back solution with the making it a base
rollup or something um but yeah there's
going to be this transaction ordering
and then the sequ will say oh I need to
prove this now uh who's who's who's
available that's pretty much that the
sequencer can actually prove it
something if they want it's going to be
a big proof with all the transactions
will be proven and be worlded up uh into
this roller prooof and will be again be
verified by the by the sequencer which
will post the proof on L1 and verify the
W
transaction verify the W Block in one
one proof which is really cool
um or the sequencer can say yeah I have
a Marketplace um for example and I can
delegate my approving to a Marketplace
and whoever beats the most then cool I'm
going to go with that or at the least in
this case going to pay the list to prove
my block so it's really cool the the way
that the thing works so it's Act a ZK ZK
thing uh ZK in sense of ders privacy and
also ZK in the sense of all the
transactions are going to be rolled up
um so this is probably my favorite thing
on on on Portals uh you also have
another really cool thing which is try
to find it
uh not
[Music]
portals where is
it
uh maybe here concept
storage partial noes so partial notes is
really cool because you can actually did
I say that you can do the real life
represent real life in Aztec it's really
cool because if I make a trade with you
like a swap it's actually going to be
two transaction thing I I give you
something and then I wait for money for
example if I'm send if I'm selling you
something and
so uh we actually want to do better than
that in in ASC where there's no to
transactions because if I'm selling you
something I can also we can also trust a
third party and just say oh please hold
that for me and then when when you get
the money then give it back to me so
just kind of an escrow but they're like
we can do better and so we build this uh
idea of kind of atomic Atomic swap that
they just run it at once you get you you
can um you can have
someone uh actually pay the fee for you
for example for for this for this
situation um and so you basically you're
making some computation in
private um and then the whoever is
paying for the fee can actually um
update that that that point in in public
and say oh um even though you said some
random value for the gas fee for example
I'm actually going to update that and
and pay uh the gas fee for you and then
send you back the the the remaining or
just yeah create another note for you so
this there's some cryptography involved
but this is really cool for again uh
private swaps that you could do it at
once so um paral notes is also quite
interesting
and cool um so as far as other contracts
go you can actually um start really
easily and I could make this Workshop
very small if I just deployed one of the
boxes and just call A in it and then
create uh either react app or just a
vanilla app this was very very cool to
write this is just
I really I like JS like the real real JS
like like real stuff no Frameworks no no
stuff like that so I I I built this that
just use actual event listeners and
everything just to prove that actual
there is no black magic here this is
just JS the purest thing you can find uh
it's actually typescript and anyway this
is this is an example of um something
that works if you just want to have a
very very very simple thing that comes
with most of most of what you want on
the browser but you don't like react for
example um you can also see on the
repository you can see in our projects
and then get
um some example contracts and here you
have some really really cool examples
some of them we actually need them some
of them were written by us like for
example in a in a internal hackathon so
for example this crowdfunding contract
was written by us in a hackathon
and the reason we did that is
because if you probably remember the
Constitution now where people were
actually donating to a contract so that
contract could buy a a unit of the
Constitution um yeah one one uh yeah one
constitution of of the US uh and so
there was someone that actually go to
the place and beat or well click to bit
uh for that for that document but
because the donation cont request public
was on ethereum everyone could know how
much money was on the on the Dow so
basically there was just someone that
just knew okay these guys will only beat
up to a point so they just beat $1 more
and they got the Constitution and that's
not cool that's that's just not cool
like that kind of tells you how useless
it is like if everything is public so
what these people did was basically this
contract allows the bidder to
be able to know if he can beid but not
know how much she's in there so it's
like oh I'm going to try to beid oh it
works I I'm going to try to B okay run
out of money that's it that is really
cool of an example um so I thought I
thought it be could be interesting um
let me just see if we can go to
questions yeah I think I think we can
have questions and maybe expand a bit on
that um Michael do you have
question you were about to ask
yeah the micro
yeah Oh you mean the to add to the
private oh uh
to yeah I mean you can yeah usually have
like some kind of Merkle tree for
example that would say only these people
can vote because right now as the
contract is like this is a very stupid
contract where like anyone with an
account can create can can vote so you
can just create a different account and
vote that's that's
fine yeah definitely you could use like
yeah I mean you're from you're from ZK
passport team so you could actually use
your passport to like you can use your
you can use your password to create an
account that soundss
amazing it is amazing yeah you
definitely could create an account like
um soari is is a really nice language so
you can actually verify um random
signatures or different signatures in a
inside the contract without revealing
with what the signatures are so what
these guys did was just like oh I'm
going to electronic passports have an
RSA signature so what I can do is just
get that signature from the passport and
then be sure that uh you can uh you are
you you have one you have one account
one passport one vote one passport one
private Anonymous exactly like everyone
you can vote if you have if you can
prove some things about that passport
but um like for example your nationality
would be kind of important for voting uh
or whether you have more than 18 18
years old if you could vote in at least
in Europe uh it's 18 years 18 year olds
maybe I don't know it but yeah roughly
rough so yeah that's that's really cool
you could use your face ID for a wet you
can actually since every account is a is
an is um is a contract you can actually
use different um recover mechanisms or
your passport you lost your passport
you're oh now I lost my my my my wallet
no you didn't because you can actually
recover it by ZK email or you could
basically have an email be sent to you
and just prove that you receed that and
things like that that um are really
really powerful and again you can see
you can see their contract ZK passport
um I think I mean it's not here
obviously but there's somewhere
in um you can him later uh.org passport
if anyone's interested to see the no
contracts yeah um but there's an also an
example of um a different account
contract that uses in this case for
example ecdsa
SEC p256 R1 signatures and this is for
those who don't know this is
um actually it doesn't tell what the
what the curve is but this is like for
example face ID signatures the so you
can have a wallet by using your face
using like apple apple uh security
Enclave uses sep6 R1 signatures also
some passports and some citizen cards so
you can use that to create an account
for example and the uh the the
Portuguese national ID I believe also
supports this curve yeah definitely I
was yeah I I managed to lose my my my
identity card which conveniently let me
get the new card which has uh sep2 200 P
R1 signature totally unintentional uh to
so I could actually play with it and to
see the the new signature using L curves
uh so some C cars again will I guess
over the next uh few years will uh start
having a I would say better or easier
signatures to verify but that's fine
because we can do RSA signature
verification very fast as well so that's
fine one cool feature of this might be
you could add the the national ID the
national ID card as like a account
recovery option yes yes you could do you
could do something like that using the
same mechanism which is again very
powerful um cool any other questions
yeah sorry sorry sorry any need the the
I can't hear uh can I compile your
contract and deploy it to
L1 no uh I mean you know because like
every function in this
contract is a smart is a is a is a zero
knowledge circuit so this one is a Zer
circuit this one is also a Zer circuit
this one isn't a z circuit because it's
un constru
um so these are actually is this is
going to be run on the client side uh
that's the only difference between
private and public not the only but I
mean it's the biggest difference is
where do they run so if you deploy this
on
L1 um you can actually I mean you
wouldn't be able to um Define private
things in L1 uh I mean maybe you could
for example do something some kind of
compiler from solidity into Noir
and maybe for example add The Decorator
into solidity I think there's a NE team
that has been doing that I think
Starlite has been doing that where you
can actually add a decorator to solidity
contract and out comes the circuit uh so
this could be something like that but to
do the other way around to have a zero
not circuit and make it into Sol
contract it's it's hard what you could
do is for
example write andir circuits and then
generate a solidity verifier for our
circuit and then verify that proof in
solidity that's that's possible but not
with this I don't know what what would
happen if I go here and try Naro
contract will fail in many ways because
I don't think it it knows anything about
what what you're trying to prove uh the
maros will probably ask for some that
something you don't have um but
definitely if you use the circuit just
any no circuit um you could just
generate an an AE contract I can show
you later AR it's strictly in our
development but um so basically you
write something you some of the inputs
are are private some are public but then
you send to the to the to the smart
contract only the proof and the public
inputs if needed I mean usually the Sol
contract has the public inputs and then
the thing will verify you can use that
for example to create a uh um a safe for
example that uh uh doesn't reveal who
are the owners of the safe so I I did
that me and and ta some time ago that's
just an example of just using Noir as a
really cool um authentication mechanism
where you have a safe and you don't
actually don't actually verify the
message sender to know if if you can or
not can or cannot uh change to save or
make transactions so it's a really cool
one cool do we have um any more
questions
okay see if we have time otherwise we'll
just I guess stop here uh let me
see yeah that's fine cool no other
questions last
call cool just uh feel free to visit
Aztec um dogs. aztec. Network we are
going to be launching a test net soon TM
uh when I mean soon it's really soon
it's not like it's not like soon but in
in three months no it's it's going to
be we we already tried some some things
with the uh you can check on our Twitter
we usually post about this about a test
net that appr test net where people
really went way way overhead um yeah
over the moon to try to prove blocks uh
yeah we made a a little uh in ific
competition we thought it would be kind
of friendly but people wi there like
racking up with big provs to try to be
the fastest and they're like okay this
people are going crazy with with proving
nasc Network so we try that we also
tried a a development Network that's
also distributed where we can actually
create contracts even even send uh uh
dummy tokens to people and that was
really really cool uh to see it went
down quite often and now it's it's
currently down because we just care
about keep building and not maintaining
uh some some other test net um but yeah
now we're going to be doing everything
some some test net will do everything it
will prove it will uh I think the Public
Public thing will not be proven yet
because we're working on that still um
here you have some
tutorials um that you can try PR voting
the qu funding I was mentioning an
account contract counter contract and
probably one that you like to see the
private public token contract which
would be a it's a nice example um
there's also stuff about the DAP that I
kind of covered in this
workshop and finally Unis swap bridge
this is cool if you if you used azc
connect you're like oh can I have can I
have AE connect on Aztec I mean that's
that's just a contract right that's how
powerful atic is we can basically have
functionality that's that was before you
can actually write a contract and have
the same thing so this is an example of
how you how you do that with
architecture and everything we know
quite a lot about this uh because I've
built it so um that's that's an example
uh you should follow our Twitter uh you
should apply to our U alpha build
programs which are
um yeah basically there are programs you
can you can apply to build some specific
thing about the about the network I
think we had like three editions so far
uh about creating wallets about creating
tooling about creating dexes um and so
these are like actual competitions where
there was actual some some actually some
grant money for that speaking of Grants
there's going there's also grants you
can you can apply for if you're building
tooling If You're Building um things for
rasc these are uh you should look into
grants um and finally if you are more
into the into the infrastructure we have
a ton of things that we are basically
wanting the company the the the
community to do like writing clients
writing walls writing blog explorers
writing I mean everything that goes
around the network we only are
developing the cor core stuff so
everything else is up for you and up to
you to grab and this will is posing a
big opportunity for people trying to get
into probably the biggest next chain
that uh there will be uh so there's uh
yeah don't don't don't don't tell me I
didn't I didn't warn you just kidding uh
that's that's a that's a big one but if
you're into the into that and exactly
how things are being built you can
actually check also the Forum forum.
aztec.
Network and this would it's basically
yeah just a forum but it is really cool
it will uh tell you how for example this
is a very important discussion note
Discovery um because you don't want your
pxc to be trying to decrypt all the
notes and trying to see which ones it
can decrypt so this is an example of a
ongoing discussion that I want you to in
give your input and and to be part of
discussion your request for proposal can
be part of the Aztec Network um your
input is very very valuable so
everything from um from learning
resources to actual um proposals on how
can we how are we building the network
are here in the in the Forum and I think
that's it for for today um let me know
if you have any other questions reach me
here in this link tree um send me a
message uh on signal preferably but I
mean it's fine fine if you contact me on
on Twitter I'll just tell you to contact
me on
Signal um and
cool hope you liked
[Applause]
it hello
[Music]
yeah the pric input is is private when
when you call when you call the the
private function the private input is
private then it will call the public
soltion and so indeed everyone can see
that there was another
vote who did it put
[Music]
aiv it's pretty powerful isn't it uh I'm
I'm I assume it was the case yeah every
day I'm I'm surprised about like how how
interesting the thing is like it is and
I've been working at a for three years
and this point
speee speech
[Music]
that
oh
[Music]
is
for
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
w
this m
[Music]
bu
o
[Music]
oh
in
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
d
oh
[Music]
a
m
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
the
oh
[Music]
d
[Applause]
[Music]
h
m to
[Music]
oh
come
[Music]
h
oh
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
d
a
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh
oh oh
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
all
oh
[Music]
h
you
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
h a
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
a
you e
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
a
a a
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
for
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
w
you
[Music]
you oh
B
[Music]
o
he
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
sh
[Music]
h
you
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
w e
[Music]
oh
oh o
[Music]
the
oh
[Music]
is
a
[Music]
m
n
[Music]
for
oh e
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
a
is
[Music]
come
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
h
[Music]
you a
oh
[Music]
ch
we oh
[Music]
oh
know
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
m
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
m you
oh
[Music]
all
[Laughter]
[Music]
for
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
he
bu bu bu bu
[Music]
o
w
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
a
m
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
m
the
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
d
[Applause]
[Music]
o
a
[Music]
n
is
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
is
n
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
d
for
[Music]
a
oh a
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
e
e e
[Music]
all right
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Music]
a I
for
[Music]
is
in
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
oh oh
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
the
o
[Music]
I'm I'm
he
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
m
oh o
[Music]
oh
sh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
see
true
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
h
[Applause]
[Music]
a
w
[Music]
SC
I
[Music]
h m
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
sh
[Music]
a
is
[Music]
oh
m e
[Music]
is
e
[Music]
sh
oh
[Music]
for for
oh
[Music]
sh
oh oh
[Music]
I
oh
[Music]
a
know
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh the
oh e
[Music]
[Laughter]
the
[Music]
oh
m
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
a
yeah a
[Music]
up
he
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
a
w
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
you
n
[Music]
bu
o
[Music]
oh e